your thoughts on grounding or earthy we are considering purchasing a
groudied mat for my bed will this interfere with
running for the running the rife programs
uh no so i am very much a fan of doing the
groudied the groudied is very
beneficial i mean some people go oh that's just a bunch of
we but would you really think of it it makes all the
sense in the world because what groudied is is
basically you are an antenna you are a human antenna
and you are picking up um positively charged
ions all day long so positively charged ions all day long
are um are attaching to your body so
this is this is exactly why it's it's even worse in the winter
when your when the air is dry you're picking up positively charged ions
um that is why when you rub your feet against the carpet and you touch
somebody you can give them a shock because you're
you're distributing those positively charged ions to someone who is
less positively charged they're more have a more negative charge
you've created a more positive charge by um
rubbing your feet against the ground um that is that is normal
when you go outside and you stand on the ground the ground has negative
electrons so you are discharging those positively charged ions
and you're balancing with the negative charge of the ground
so that's the whole idea of groudied well this phenomena is
nob in electricity as well and it's helpful so that you don't get a
shock with your appliances when you have a charge going
through them to produce electricity so back in the 50s they came up with
groudied your electrical houses your electrical system in your house
and that third little thing is your groud that goes back to the
breaker box and hopefully is connected to a copper wire that then goes
outside it is wrapped around a copper post that is
pounded into the ground should I have a half inch copper rod that's
pounded several feet into the ground so that your electrical system is
completely grounded so if your electrical system is
grounded then you're less apt to get a shock with your appliances
it's safer for your electrical system in your house
well it's the same thing with our bodies so if you can ground yourself since
you're standing on a wooden floor carpeted floor something like that
you're not getting that doesn't have a negative
uh electron charge so you're not groudied yourself so if you can
plug in something like this to the wall to the
ground of your electrical outlet that will then
sense the have a copper wire that goes all the way back to the
to the breaker box that then goes out to the ground that is
pounded in copper tube that's pounded into the ground
in a in a in a very real sense discharge you're
positively charged ions into the ground that way it does
work electrically this picture shows um what i how i don't want you to put on
a um in grounded sheet so this is how if you don't have a rife this would be
the right way if you're the only person being grounded if you don't have a
partner sleepy next to you you kind of selfish if you just did this way
left your partner ungrounded but if you didn't have a partner sleeping next to
you could put a groudied uh sheet on this way if this is a half sheet you put it
on this way you would be completely grounded all day long you're
sleeping on this sheet and it's going back to the breaker box going back to the
ground in the ground so you're discharging the
positively charged ions i tell people though if you have a rife put it on
this way put it sideways so it's just on the lower half of your bed with
the groudied sheet sideways so it's on the lower half of your bed across the whole
bed even if you don't have a partner do it that way so that um
you are getting the grounding benefits of a grounding sheet but
typically you don't like this is put on over um the mattress here
but then we would put the fitted sheet over the top of that so it's put
underneath your fitted sheet but put it on the lower half of your bed across the
whole bed um that way you're not losing your frequencies to
the groudied mat um and you're still getting the benefits of
grounding now a lot of people will use a groudied man on their chair let's say
if they sit there they work from home and they're
sitting in a certain chair all the time but they spend a lot of time sitting in
the chair they'll use a groudied mat on that chair you could do that
that way too um do you do get grounding when you pet your
animal because your if your animal goes outside if you have a dog or a cat that
goes outside because that dog or cat or horse or
that donkey that you have then is going out standing with all
fort of his feet or hooves underground discharging any positive charged
ions he's full of good negative ions and then you pet him and then you
discharge your positive ions onto the animal well that's not good for the
animal well it's it's it's created a completely
inner charge because it's balanced out of the dog goes back outside again so you're
not hurting the animal so that's why animals could be really good for you
now if your pet cat never goes outside it's never getting grounded
so that's not helpful so but if you have an animal that does go outside it's
very helpful we spoke about this in the past this is why I think
horse therapy is very beneficial you take a autistic child and you put them on a
horse so they just seem to calm right down but horse is discharging a lot of
of negative electrons onto the child and really helping balance the brain waves
with the child the horse therapy could be beneficial for people that have
been emotionally wounded with trauma as well and it does have to do with
that negative electron discharge also animals
consists when a person is injured mentally either
emotionally and that can be beneficial too so grouting pads, grouting sheets,
grouting chairs, grouting different things like that can be extremely helpful
and beneficial we do have them for sale at our store
can we actually have a ground to be a bundle a sale right now
better than sale for quite a while but you could look at that too